how you don't know Orleans a beautiful
goddamn City be the first to see the
next big names in stand-up on Comedy
Central stand up presents you guys could
probably tell this by looking at me but
I have been fired a lot Hillary
like she was supposed to be my bitch and
I hated her the whole time like I voted
for but only because Barack Toki's you
know you wish somebody passed a year and
it still holding you all night you were
dating a serial killer
I'm great at it I was sitting that being
black I was like you know what give me
another thing Colorado some Chile's do I
tie a little bandana round my dog's neck
I don't know it depends how chill I'm
feeling another fun fact about me is
that I am almost always doing exactly
what a trump supporter imagines that I'm
doing it's a lot of fun I can't hang out
people like windbreakers does it sound
like the whispering secrets
whose penis is so small you feel like
you want to fill out a w-9 so you get
money at internet listen your buttholes
up let's get what I'm working with I'm
gonna get a little nasty at the
beginning of yoga class and they ask you
to set your intention and I always set
my intention for revenge in the middle
of kissing she told me that she want me
to choke her now I don't know about you
guys I have arthritis in my hands if an
old lady in a nursing home said the
n-word and all her friends are deaf did
she really say I create expertise I
didn't realize that you needed to wear a
sports bra and I almost ripped my hips
up skinny girls still take an Instagram
picture maybe show a little boob a
little bit of but people are like oh
what it's split there's such a I do
it they're like oh comedy central's
stand-up presents premieres Friday
September 15th at midnight
[Music]